tomorrow when the post-mortems take
place in the press and television a
great deal of time and space will be
concerned with who or what and how they
looked at tonight's ceremonies fashion
and films have always been linked
together our memory of Marilyn Monroe is
almost inseparable from the white dress
that billowed up above her waist in the
7-year itch and the white outfit worn by
Peter O'Toole in Lawrence of Arabia said
as much as words about the coolness of
the character costumes tell us in a
vivid shorthand a great deal about the
person the place and a period of the
film these are the costume designers who
have made such a significant
contribution to the film's they were
assigned to bring to life
for The Adventures of Priscilla Queen of
the desert
nominees lizzy gardner and tim chapel
made the outrages acceptable in bullets
over Broadway nominee Geoffrey Kurland
found the right note to recreate the
colorful fashions of the roaring 20s the
grand look of the 19th century was
captured by nominee Colleen Atwood for
the film version of Louisa May Alcott's
Little Women the old was West never
looked better or more authentic than
under the watchful eye of nominee April
ferry and her costume designs for
maverick elegance is always a challenge
to recreate but the designs of nominee
model Vicco for Queen Margot delivered
on every count and the Oscar goes to and
the Oscar goes to Lizzie Gardner and Tim
Chapel for the Adventures of Priscilla
Queen of the desert
well I was surprised we'd like to thank
firstly the costume designers who
nominated this in the first place
because that was definitely one of the
best compliments we've ever had and
thank you to the Academy for voting for
us it's much heavier than it looks I
tell you and my turn okay um
I'd like to thank girls definitely and I
wish he was here and he should be I'd
like to thank al Clark and Michael
Hamlin the whole cast and crew Priscilla
they are wonderful and we wish to God
they were here to Polygram pictures
gramercy Michael [ __ ] and the Academy
thank you so much I think we need to go
and cry with some dignity now thank you
need a drink
sorry I'm telling you American Express
can't buy publicity like that